let's take a look at the unit circle
okay if you look at these four points 1
0 0 1 negative 1 0 and 0 negative 1
remember on the unit circle the cosine
is the x-coordinate the sine is the
y-coordinate so let's graph sine first
we're gonna graph these points so if we
graph sine y equals sine X okay so if we
graph it at 0 degrees okay sine is the
y-coordinate that's 0 okay at 90 degrees
sine is 1 at 180 degrees sine is back
down to 0 at 270 sine is negative 1 and
then over here at 360 degrees we've made
one revolution we're back to 0 and
that's how we get our our sine graph
okay so there's a 1 cycle 1 period and
it keeps repeating okay that's a sine
wave now if we want to graph cosine
we're going to look at the x coordinate
so at 0 degrees cosine is 1 so it starts
up here at the max then at 90 degrees it
goes to 0 and at 180 degrees it's down
to negative 1
270 it's back to 0 and 360 degrees
you're back to 1 so if you graph cosine
one period looks like that so this is 2
pi if you divide the period into 4
pieces 2 pi divided by 4 is PI over 2 pi
3 PI over 2 and 2 pi and it's the same
thing for our cosine so that comes from
the unit circle now what happens if we
want to graph y equals
to sign of X okay the two here this is
affecting the vertical stretch this is
the amplitude this number here right in
front of the sign okay so what that
means is we're gonna go up now two
positive two down to negative two and
back to zero so all we do is we
stretched it okay so this is the
amplitude that affects the vertical
stretch let's say if we go down to this
graph for the cosine say we want to
graph y equals cosine of two times x
cosine of 2x so what's happening here is
this number here in front of the X
sometimes this is referred to as B and
you can use this formula period equals
two pi divided by B so if you take two
pi the normal period for sine and cosine
divide it by this coefficient the number
in front of the X here we will get two
pi divided by two which equals pi so
what that means is this graph is
actually going twice as fast so if I was
to graph this graph this here it would
go like this
there is one cycle and then another
cycle so you can see it actually
completed two periods and the normal 2pi
so it's twice as fast or you can think
of it as completing one period right
here and pi okay so that's the basic
idea for the amplitude and this B value
which affects the period through this
formula here that you can use two PI
over B to help calculate your period the
next thing is shifting the graph to the
left and right up and down so if we take
a look at let's say we were to go like
this y equals sine of X minus PI over 2
okay so here the number group with the X
that's going to shift this graph in the
X direction this x axis direction here
okay
- pi over 2 is going to shift it
positive PI over 2 to the right if this
is plus PI over 2 it shifted to the left
PI over 2 so each of these points I'm
just going to be shifting to the right
this point here this point over here
this point over here at this point over
here and you can see now the graph
shifting to the right PI over 2 now
let's go down to this one at the bottom
cosine let's say we were to graph y
equals cosine of X plus 1 so what does
the one do it's in that group of the X
it's not in parentheses like this one
the plus one is actually just going to
shift the entire graph up one so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
this graph that's drawn in black and I'm
going to shift it up one unit so I'm
just going to go up one-up one-up one-up
one and up one and there is my graph
shift it up one unit ok so those are the
basic operations amplitude this is if
called a phase shift it shifts it left
and right you've got a vertical shift
this one's shifting up one this is
affecting the period this is the B value
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to try to combine these together
into some more difficult problems
graphing sine and cosine so let me just
erase this rule quickly and let's take a
look at some more challenging problems
okay we're going to try to do one that
involves all all of them together ok
we'll do one for sine we'll do one for
cosine so you can see how this works ok
so say for example we want to graph y
equals 3 sine one-half X minus PI to ax
plus pi minus one okay now every teacher
is a little bit different your teacher
might be different in this regard but
she'll get the sense of what you can do
based on what I'm about to show you
we're going to do this in steps we're
going to graph the amplitude and the
period in one step that's the parent
function and then we're going to do the
translation the shift
left and right and up and down in the
second step so let me see if I can show
you what I mean by that so first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to graph
the parent function sine graph starts at
0 goes up to the maximum back down to
the 0 back to the minimum back to 0
ok the amplitude is 3 so 1 2 3 that's
the max 1 2 negative 3 that's the min
and now we're gonna use our formula
period equals 2 pi divided by B so that
gives us a period of 4 pi so it's
completing one cycle and 4 pi so this is
4 pi here I'm going to take 4 PI minute
divide it into 4 pieces 1 2 3 4 so that
our scale is PI now PI 2 pi 3 PI and 4
PI this is our basic graph that's a and
B now we're going to shift the graph
left PI remember this one has the
opposite effect
so left PI and down 1 ok so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take each of
these points and I'm gonna shift left PI
so that's going to everyone's going to
go left PI and down one left PI down one
left PI down one left PI let's see we
just from here left PI down 1 and left
PI down 1 so if I connect these together
here smooth curve there is our graph and
sometimes what you can do is you can
draw this dotted line here like that and
even like this you can think of this as
your new starting point instead of
graphing from the origin here this
shifted left PI and down 1 you can think
of that as your new origin and you're
just graphing this graph from here say 0
max 0 men back to the 0 ok so that's one
example of sine let's do another one
with cosine and see if you can get the
pattern of how this works do it in steps
I think that's what makes it easiest
let's graph this one here y equals
negative two cosine let's say 4x minus
PI plus three okay this is a good one
here a little bit of everything here so
let's start by graphing two cosine 4x
now what I want to show you here in this
parenthesis ideally what you want is
just one X so what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna factor out that 4 let's do
that right now that's going to be 4 if
we divide this by 4 and this by 4 we get
X minus PI over 4 you can check your
work by distributing 4 back in you'll
get back this quantity here so let's
just copy that down negative plus 3 okay
so we just rewrote it okay so if we
graph our cosine graph normally what our
cosine graph looks like is it starts at
the max goes to the min back to the max
like that the amplitudes 2 1 2 1
negative 2 and the period is going to be
2 pi divided by 4 so period equals 2 pi
divided by 4 so that's going to be PI
over 2 so it's completing one cycle here
and PI over 2 if you divide it up into 4
pieces okay the scale is going to be PI
over 8 so 1 PI R 8 2 PI over 8 3 PI over
8 4 PI R 8 which is PI over 2
okay but what are we gonna do with this
negative over here what is the negative
do it makes all the Y values the
opposite so it's going to reflect over
the x-axis so what our graph looks like
now is like this
see it reflected it okay now what we're
gonna do is were gonna shift everything
right PI over four Q remember this is
minus actually has the opposite effect
so write PI over four up three so every
one of these points is going to shift
right PI over four which on our scale is
actually going to be two PI over eight
so it's two steps to the right and up
three so let's do that so this is going
to go right to one two up three one two
three
okay this point here is going to go
right to up three that's one two three
right about here okay this one over here
is going to go right to one two up three
which is going to be let's see right
about let's see this was right two up
three right over here and let's see make
sure I got this right here so we've got
that right 2 up 3 right 2 up 3 this one
right 2 up 3 okay so the graph is
looking like this now it's like okay so
it's this blue graph that's been shifted
up 3 and right 2 steps and so you can
see that's the new graph so what I
recommend I ran out of little space here
as you can see but uh you want to do the
a and the B together and then you can do
the shift second ok so that's the idea
for graphing sines and cosines we'll
talk about graphing tangent cotangent
secant and cosecant and one of the next
videos